phòng phòng viên, là một nhà lãnh đạo chú chốt của đàn nhân dân kết mạng lào. Người có nhiều đống có quan trọng
đúng vi sự việc khác mạng lào cũng như trong công cuộc mạo việc xây dựa và phát triển đất nước lào.
Đúng chỉ là nhà lãnh đạo có phát trọng quan trọng, cho việc kế thừa vùng đáp và phát triển
mối quan hệ hỗ nghị vị đại vành kết nặng miệt hợp tác toàn dị et gản kết chiến lược Việt Nam
lào. Đúng chỉ mất đi là một tổng thất to lương, đúng với tất nước lào và quan hệ Việt Nam
lì tò lòng thương việc đồng chi sây sòng phòng phòng viên và suốt phát được quan hệ hệ Việt Nam
lào. Màng cho bánh trưng đàn cụm sản Việt Nam, của khổ nước cộng hà sà hội trụ với Việt Nam,
cho tỉnh nước cộng hà sà hội trụ với Việt Nam, chính phủ nước cộng hà sà hội trụ với Việt Nam
và bị bán trung ước mặt trận tổ của Việt Nam, quất định lệ tăng đồng chi sây sòng phòng phòng viên
theo nghĩ thức cuốc tăng trong hàng ngày từ ngày 1 mời, đến ngày 1 mùi một tháng cảm nâng ngày 9-12-12
bí sấu trong thời gian này các cơ quan công sở trong phạc vi cản nước và các cơ quan đại dịt của Việt Nam
tại nước ngoài chào cơ dụ có giải măng tăng như quy định không tổ chức các hoạt động vui chưa giải trí cộng cộng